this guy's always interesting just ask
him he'll tell you
he's uh brian cranston the actor uh well
you i don't even know how to dis uh
introduce you you're a lot of things but
uh
you're a friend of the show and
therefore we're friends of whatever you
do so it's great to see you how are you
i'm good dan i'm uh i'm you know
just getting through like like everybody
else like our entire country is just
trying to figure out
what this new normal looks like when we
all go back to work and
all that stuff it's odd it's and it's
also odd how we're also
adapting to it and just kind of
accepting the new
the new protocols and things of work but
i see where
there's things being uh like uh keanu
reeves has done matrix
in berlin i think or someplace like just
trying to
like how does an actor get together to
do
projects here if you can't go or social
distancing or travel all those things
it's difficult uh especially in our
business where
intimacy is inherent in the in the work
i mean embracing
lovemaking kissing shaking hands i mean
it's all part of
storytelling and so it's going to be
extremely difficult
for film production at any scale any
significant scale to be
able to come back before a vaccine so
we'll see
but then you got covered back in what
was that april when you got it
march even like the first the first week
uh when we were shut down i was doing a
limited series
in new orleans um called your honor
and it was having a good time we had
about two more episodes to shoot
shut down on the 13th of march by the
following week
i was diagnosed with covet who was like
bang bang
and you know what was the symptoms or
did you know you were sick
well first my wife uh tested and
she was tested positive and i i just
assume well
we've been together for the last 10 days
straight
i'm i'm it's impossible not to get it
from her so
and i did we were very fortunate that
uh our symptoms were very mild we had a
couple days of achiness and then
um you know about a week of
absolute exhaustion it's just one of
those times you just can't
sleep enough who's a better
covered testing positive actor you or
tom hanks
oh there's there's no question that i
excel
at testing positive
yes there's a there's a little
confidence a weird competition look at
men or man
i know i'm stupid anyways so tom
told me about the he gave me the address
and the
contact name of the person to uh to set
up
to for have me start a plasma donation
program and so i did and i
said you know over time your your
antibodies will diminish and
your plasma may not be as effective as
it as they
hope so hopefully you can do it twice or
three times and so i'm going back
actually the day after tomorrow to for
my third
donation of plasma and
uh that and i just wanted to find out
from tom
so how how potent was your antibodies
how many times were you able to do it
you know oh only twice
only no that's a shame only twice my
antibodies are strong my friend
doesn't it bother you how nice tom hanks
is
[Laughter]
he's uh no you know what i mean the
truth is
you can't even joke about it because
he's so good um
i've worked with him he's given me a job
i've worked with him like four times
and um i've really learned from him
how to behave not that i was going to
misbehave but how to step up
and embrace that responsibility of being
the leader of a cast which sets the tone
for the entire shoot
and how he conducts himself his
comportment
he goes to work he's prepared he's got a
good attitude
uh has a blast a couple you know
gags and things going on keeps the set
loose
knows everybody's name and and then goes
home so all the drama
is in the show and not around the show
and that's why everybody loves to work
with them and
there are you know a few people who have
that reputation and he's one and i was
fortunate enough to learn from that
where are you uh right now are you at
your house
i'm i'm at my house yeah okay yeah in
los angeles you don't really
you didn't dress up the backdrop you got
like a ladder you got a
piece of art you got yeah it's like uh
um
yeah it's like a piece of art back what
do you mean i didn't dress up my
background well
just because look at you look at you you
have tchotchkes all over the place yes
yes i love tchotchkes
tom hanks would have an oscar behind him
right now if he was on this
show no that's that's why he wouldn't
have an oscar behind him
that's how good he is i got a i got a
couple of emmys around here too that i
just
like straggling a couple over here how
come you don't put him in the shot
i you know that would be rubbing it in
yeah you know it's just not fair
rubbing it into your competition yes
who do you feel is your biggest
competitor in in
as brian turns the tables on mr patrick
okay i see what you've done there yeah
who is my
it's me because i compete with myself
every day
there's nobody who could provide
something
who would uh make me feel like that's a
direct competitor there are great people
in this
business but i compete against my what
the danettes are calling
us over there
are you andy reid what kind of answer
was that i was trying to be politically
correct
okay who is my competition dance paulie
well like
a list of people you hate me i can't do
the ones i start with hate don't mention
the hate ones don't mention them
all right so yeah you could address it
up there a little bit
that's all oh god that's you go that's
your that's how you sub diffuse
yes the question was who do you feel
you're in competition with
who do you who do you look at and go
that guy is good or that woman is really
good at what she does
i wish i can rise to that level uh well
bob costas is always going to be there
i mean he isn't he yeah i mean he's okay
but he's he's in my sights uh
even though he's got i think about 28
more sports emmys than i do
um yeah but i there's things that i take
from people that i admire like al
michael's
his ability to have composure in the
biggest moments
uh so there's so many that i look at but
anybody who wins a sports emmy i'm in
competition with them
automatically well do you do you do any
play-by-play do you do anything like
that is that something you've
wanted to do i'm not good at it
i'm just no i i could never capture
what i grew up listening to and i have
such great respect for those who do it
that
i thought i didn't want to get in the
way of somebody who i thought could do
it better than me
and that's the one part of this business
that i didn't have confidence in
the other part you know hosting the
olympics or you know a super bowl or
doing a show
uh entertaining you know a nation you
know those are things that come
naturally to me but uh
you know yeah entertaining and nature
yes thank you
i was waiting for the reaction it was a
delayed reaction there from you on that
i was i was trying to
prevent myself from choking up uh what
what actor do you hate
[Laughter]
do you have the list paulie do you have
the list of guys
oh you hate hugh jackman don't you
oh my god he is so i i hate him because
he's so nice so talented so handsome
yeah i just i i wish he would crash and
burn that guy did you see i was thinking
of you ryan reynolds
sold his gin for 600 million dollars
yeah he did that's that's a expensive
bottle of gin
wow but you know you got clooney see
it's not fair
clooney a billion dollars for his
tequila 600 million for ryan reynolds
yeah it's
it's stupid money it's stupid we have
you know aaron paul and i have our
our mezcal dos umbres yes and uh it's
going incredibly well
we're selling like insane amounts
i i think people are just drinking
[Laughter]
they are i'm right there with them you
know yeah
but the cocktails are tasty and as long
as you you know keep it in check and
you know from time to time i will i will
go i'll go
i'll say i'm not going to drink it all
this week or two weeks i just won't
drink at all
yeah and then i and then i go off and i
have a couple drinks and it's nice
you want to be able to control that but
when's the last time you were upside
down
no uh
probably 20 25 years ago oh
okay oh yeah no it's
there's something you know there's a
mechanism within boys
that is stuck most of the time and that
is
knowing when you've had enough it's just
it's like
you think you can control it and then
all of a sudden
it taps you on the shoulder and it goes
uh oh made that same mistake
uh explain to me the one and only ivan
this is a disney movie
based off a book and i saw the reviews i
didn't get to see the movie i just saw
the reviews
which look like they're very pop do you
read reviews
no no i uh i stopped reading reviews
about seven years ago or so when
when i did a movie and a reviewer came
out
and made a bunch of assumptions and and
comments that i that were really unfair
and
wrong in the assumption and i thought
well this is this just irritates me
and and then you know doing doing
theater
it's not going to change your
performance you're you you do all the
work to present what you do and if
someone
doesn't like it then they don't like it
but um i just
realized that it doesn't it doesn't help
me even the
the positive reviews i don't know it
just it
i i don't need that kind of
um you know support i
i i feel good about what i'm doing and i
present it do the best i can and then if
people like it great if they don't
that's okay too
i'd explain it because it's uh it's on
disney plus beginning this friday and
this is a family movie
and i know that uh angelina jolie is in
sam rockwell danny devito
uh just some of the people in there but
explain the concept of
the one and only ivan well this was
based on a true story there was a
husband and wife in tacoma washington
that adopted
a lowland gorilla a baby from africa
when its family was wiped out by
poachers
and this is i mean a baby in diapers and
they would take this baby
in a stroller to the park put it in
swings it drew all kinds of attention
and
news media was all over it it was quite
a thing
but this lowland gorilla grows up to be
a silverback gorilla of course and doing
what gorillas do
inside a person's home is destroy it
climbing on things pulling off the
refrigerator door
because they're curious and opening up
the couch
i mean it's it's it destroyed this house
and it actually destroyed the marriage
in real life
well it came time that the the guy who
was my character
uh he wanted to do something to keep his
son
with him so he rented a defunct um
shopping mall an indoor shopping mall in
tacoma
and and put his beloved son ivan
in that and had a de facto circus and
people would come from all around to see
ivan and then he got other animals
in other cages and there they were now
that's where we take the story
from a disney disney aspect and we
expand on it in a fantastic way and
the the animals all talk to each other
and communicate with each other
and then the live-action humans cannot
understand what the
what the animals are saying but we think
they do we've always had that
anthropomorphism where where we think
our dogs
hear us and understand what we're saying
and vice versa and
it's fantastic it's about promise
keeping and
and allowing yourself to dream it's
about friendship and it's about letting
go
and and maybe doing the right thing
um this fan this film the one and only
ivan you're
with your family you can watch it a six
year old 106 year old
you're going to get something out of
you're going to cry and you're going to
smile and laugh
it's really a lot of fun it'll be on uh
disney plus beginning
this friday it's called the one and only
ivan and you being a method actor
you actually lived with a gorilla for a
couple of months in your house is that
true
i yeah um and my wife uh
called the divorce attorney almost
immediately really yeah
but now this gorilla and i are having a
relationship
tom hanks would do that yeah no yeah
so it would cost us yeah but you would
acknowledge costas is better than me
right i well i would acknowledge that
kostas
has that fluidity that that encyclopedia
mind
to bring up those anecdotes and things
right brian you're supposed to say no
oh no no he's not better that that's
right
i'm sorry i forgot you know when you've
been on i say you're the best actor of
our generation with
you know i don't like one oh
am i supposed to say no no that's not
true well you may be
fake humility you can do that
does your wife ever say are you acting
or
are you being honest no
no i uh robin and i have a great
relationship we've been together for 33
years
and and it's it's just terrific and even
more so now in this pandemic i think
we've
deepened that i think this this
situation
will either expose the fragility of
of a marriage or or deepen it why'd you
get serious i was just having a little
bit of fun where you might be trying to
act with your wife
and you know she'd be like do you really
do you really think i look good in this
outfit are you
acting brian i listen as any good
husband
the answer is always yes unless she says
do it do you think i look fat in this
outfit then it's no
do you like my hair yes
do you like the color yes
do you like this dress yes yes
yes that is the test for any uh
new husband well that's we're both
actors
so we obviously connect on that
wavelength
i've got a i've got a bob costa's story
is it good is going to make me feel is
it good
so you want me to qualify my story first
to go can you tell it
in a minute no i can't okay
next time next time when you dress up
the uh
your office or whatever that is you know
what next time
tom hangs over in the background that
would be awesome
okay you know what i am such a fan of
bob costas
who will forever live in his shadow
thank you brian
good luck with the movie thank you dan
thank you dana it's good to talk to you
guys that's uh brian cranston disney's
the one and only ivan
it's available friday disney plus